(pulsating music)
- If you ask, how does a brain work
from an engineering perspective,
then you might ask, what is
the circuit diagram look like?
After all, if complex modern
processors are designed
and understood by engineers,
then maybe a simple brain
could be likewise
understood at that level.
Let's consider exactly
that, a simple processor.
And if you take the lid off,
you'll find underneath the die, the chip.
Looking at it a little bit closer,
you'll see that it's broken
up into various modules
for processing, for input
from various sources
and for outputs, memory and
likewise in the control.
If you look at a small
region and zoom in on it,
you'll find it's covered by a
vast mesh of tiny, tiny wires.
This is about, maybe,
a dozen layers thick.
Underneath it all, there
are the actual switches,
the transistors, which
do the switching on this.
Now if you wanna make it, you just need
a few billion dollars, machines like this,
and you're good.
If you wanna reverse engineer it,
then maybe you could use
some machines like this
as one example which I'll be discussing
in more detail called a FIB-SEM.
Now on the other end, here's
another processing unit.
Let's take the cover off and
underneath there's a brain
and it too has various
modules in it, you know,
optical inputs, called optic lobes,
antenna inputs for smell, memory units,
they all have different names,
mushroom bodies, ellipsoid
bodies, and so forth.
Studied by biologists.
So you can also zoom in
and look very carefully
and presumably, there's also gonna be
a vast mesh of wiring in there
and somehow buried in
underneath all of that
should be synapses, which
are switching between
all of these different wires.
Now if you wanna make one of these,
you need to invest in an old banana.
(audience laughing)
- And wait, not much cost,
and it'll self assemble.
And it's amazing, and
you've heard about this,
you know, in the first talk,
and it's truly amazing.
So now if you wanna reverse engineer it,
we really need, it's a tough problem,
and we need tools from
across the spectrum.
From biology, from genetics,
and I'll talk a little bit of
the aspect that can come in
from the semi-conductor
industry, that FIB-SEM.
So just to put a perspective,
let's put some dimensions on these
and compare them side-by-side.
A current processor is sort
of a flattened structure,
2 1/2 dimensions, but the volume
of it is under a millimeter.
The fruit fly, it's a nice little blob,
under a millimeter in size.
Not too different in the volume.
The number of transistors
and switches in the processor
are getting pretty impressive,
about a billion transistors nowadays.
That's a bit more than the fruit fly.
If you go back 10 years, the Pentiums,
they had about a comparable number.
And the last part, now, is the wire size
and the transistor size and the
dendrite size, synapse size,
they're all in the tens of nanometers.
Very small, and the challenge
is to bridge the gap
between the small size
of tens of nanometers
all the way up to a good
fraction of a millimeter
and catch that large, dynamic range.
So to reliably resolve these transistors
in all three dimensions,
we need to sample,
probably instead of 15 nanometers,
maybe at five or 10 nanometer increments.
These are the voxels that
you'd use to form images
and you've seen before,
one can sort of collect
many such images in 3D, form a stack.
But if you just quickly
look at the numbers,
how many voxels, how
many pixels are there?
Eight nanometers compared
to half a millimeter.
There're lots, it's a good
fraction of a pieta byte
and if you're acquiring the data
at a modest rate of a megahertz,
then you'd be acquiring
data for eight years,
even for something simple
as a fruit fly plane.
Now I should also point out,
we do need to really see the connectivity,
one needs to go down to the EM level,
to the electron microscope level.
Light microscopy cannot
quite resolve the details
and see the fine connectivity.
Light microscopy can do many
other things, image life,
so all these techniques are very
complementary and support each other.
So what is the FIB-SEM?
This is basically an
instrument where you use FIB,
which is a focused ion beam,
and it basically abrades away the surface
a few dentimeters at a time.
The advantage of an ion beam is
the abrasion is just a little bit finer,
more controlled, in the Z-dimension.
Otherwise it's very similar to what Mark
was talking about earlier,
the serial block face cutting.
After you abrade or remove a little layer,
you image the surface with
a scanning electron beam
and then you ablade again
and you cycle through this
about every minute, and
you keep going and going
for as long as you possibly
can and in the end,
you gradually reconstruct a circuit.
In this case, if you're looking
at a semi-conductor chip,
you can see all the metal layers inside.
If one's looking at a fly brain,
then you should get a
three-dimensional reconstruction
of all the details inside.
So this here is the outline
of one of these synapses,
the black part is actually
the membrane itself.
Ah, and there you can see.
So what you saw, time
here is moving in in Z
and you'll see on the
left picture right there
the dark spots, those are
actually the synapses,
they're pretty small, and this
is a typical fan in circuit,
they're multiple synapses
going all onto one dendrite.
And you see the opposite in the fly,
fan ins, fan outs, there're
just a variety of structures
that are all visible.
It's more complex than it
is for a mammalian brain.
So we got one of these
machines and started out.
And so we ran it.
Three days later,
it came to a grinding halt and stopped.
And so we imaged 1/1000 of a
brain and couldn't continue,
there were problems, and so
we came to this conclusion.
- FIB-SEM's irrelevant because it can't
image anything useful.
I continued to be employed.
(audience laughing)
And worked on the next problem,
five years of reliability engineering.
Basically to handle all of
these interrupts as they happen,
can we anticipate things,
make graceful stops if something
bad is going to happen,
mitigate damage control,
and we can restart
without loss of anything.
The bar is very high
because if you have a gap
in this dense interconnect of wiring,
there's no way that you
can connect the wires
from the left half to the right half
and you're circuit
diagram is just useless.
So you don't want to be
there imaging several years
into the project and then say oops.
So a few years later, here we are,
imaging now for about
a three months project.
That is looking at the optical lobe.
You might've noticed three pieces,
madella, lobula, and lobula plate.
And this is sort of what
you see inside a fly brain.
The motion you see is, again,
is moving in Z deeper and deeper.
Initially the width was about 120 microns,
it's about the width of two human hairs,
and in zooming in about 10x,
and we can look at detail,
and for example right
there, that's a synapse,
and it's connecting this dendrite
over to several other
guys on the other side.
It's all very subtle.
It's a big challenge
to try to pull all of that
information out and segment it.
So it took us three months to image this,
and then we gave it to some other people,
and about three years later,
they processed the data.
Processing it and analyzing it is, by far,
the bigger challenge.
This is not easy and it
requires a lot of hand effort,
or it did require a lot
of hand effort to segment,
curate, make sure there's
no mistake in there.
And what we're doing here
is dense segmentation.
We're getting, pretty
much, all of the processes,
all of the neurons, identifying them,
and then you can pull
them out, one by one,
and you find that they have their own
unique shapes and sizes
and compare them to what is
known from other experiments.
For example, some of these neurons
are coming in from the retina,
some of them are
sensitive to on-transition
or to off-transition or
to a left-to-right motion
or front-to-back motion,
and people can identify that
based on optical imaging.
But optical imaging can't tell you
the detailed synaptic connectivity,
but it can give you the classes of neuron
so one can connect the two
and bootstrap our way forward.
In addition, optical imaging
can look at life samples, too,
and tell which ones are firing
on on-transitions and off-transitions
and we can actually monitor that.
So all of that data can be put together
and you can begin to
identify the components
of a circuit diagram.
And these are the three major
parts that you saw earlier,
the madella, the lobula,
and the lobula plate.
Up here's the retina.
The thing is with the FIB-SEM,
it allows you to make the
last little connection,
which is to ask, here's one neuron,
which we know reacts to a
left-to-right on-transition,
what are its inputs?
And you can define the neurons that are
responsible for that,
characterize those independently,
and we make this last step,
and then you can begin
to test models of the circuit.
Is this a coincidence detector
based on exutory inputs,
is it a different version of that,
a nor-detector where you might have
an inhibitory input on one side.
And it turns out that it's a little bit
a combination of both are
present in the fly brain,
and you can even sort of get estimates
of what might be causing the delay
based on the length on the synapse.
So having this extra level of detail
helps close a lot of open gaps.
So so far, we still haven't
gotten to the full fly brain
and we reverted to another technique
called hot knife sectioning
to get all the way up.
Imagine the fly brain,
you chop it up into, like,
a loaf of bread, into about 30 pieces,
each about 20 nanometers thick.
You put it on a little laminated surface
and you have about 30 of these tabs
and feed them in to a bunch of machines.
And this puts us in the range of getting
this eight FIB-SEM year effort
maybe down to a little
bit more reasonable time.
And we are gearing up and trying
to expand toward this direction here.
And so far, over the past two years,
we've come just a little
ways along that path.
Looking in here, we have what we've
accomplished called a hemi brain.
It aspires to be half a brain,
but it's a little bit shy of it.
It's on a female fly, but it's unilateral
over a good part of it,
misses some aspects, you know,
too much on the optic lobe,
missing the parts below
which are associated with
feeding and appetite,
but a lot of modules are in there.
The central complex,
which is sort of an internal
compass for the fly,
and people are studying
that independently.
Olfactory learning and the mushroom body,
lateral horns, all these
names are dear to biologists
studying different parts of the fly brain.
Here's what that looks like.
That big round circle,
the donut that you saw,
that's the ellipsoid body,
and that's associated with its navigation,
sort of an internal compass of the fly.
And here we're just sort
of flying through the data
and you can just sort of see the complex.
Here we're getting pretty close at this,
you know, resolution isn't as beautiful
as what Mark has with the
dedicated high-res microscope,
but we're doing, right
here, as we fly in and out,
that's going across that section.
We have to make sure that
section has good enough quality
that we can match the dendrites
from one side to the other without loss.
That's critical.
And I'll just let this play a little bit.
It's amazing that this thing self-wires
and it looks so disorganized
but in the end it really is organized.
And there are the different
modules, we're zooming back out.
Here you can see the whole upper head
of the fly brain there.
Remember, these are several slabs
and we're just gonna
go through six of them,
we have 13 altogether.
This represents about two years
of imaging that we've done.
We've just sort of completed this.
And what will come next after this,
we want to go over, try
looking at a male fly,
but doing it now in its
entirety all the way
and that'll be a larger imaging effort.
And here we are back
to the central complex.
So what's next?
That data is not good enough by itself,
it needs some processing,
and it goes off to experts,
computer science experts
who use neural nets,
and there've been a lot of
fascinating developments
in the past few years of what they can,
how quickly they can extract it,
so they are now maybe at the level
where instead of taking 10
times longer than imaging,
they might almost be able to keep up
and pull out the nerves and get
these connectivity diagrams,
what nerve connects to
what, out of the thousands,
hundreds of thousands to
different nerves in there
and give those to biologists
so that can be correlated
with all the other information
that they work with.
So, like to put this
technology, this FIB-SEM,
on a little diagram like this
just to show where it
might fit into the world.
The bottom axis is size.
We're looking at relative
larger size structures,
it's getting close to a millimeter,
little bit below that for the fly brain.
And the vertical axis is resolution.
There's some techniques out
there, as Mark talked about,
which can get much better resolution,
but the size is going to be
a little bit more limited
and we're playing this trade
off between size and resolution
and I think FIB-SEM has a
little bit of a sweet spot,
and fly brain sort of demands
some of those attributes.
Now the FIB-SEM can also be used
in a different modality where you can
operate it with lower current.
And in there, one might be
able to image, let's say,
a whole cell with higher resolution.
The whole cell's smaller in
volume but higher resolution.
And images, instead of
being blurry like this,
can be somewhat crisper,
and we can see a more detail
of the synapse in the
bottom slide over here,
like right down here, post
synaptic vesicles over here,
individual ribosomes can be imaged
and at the top, we can
even see microtubuals.
This is just a random
piece of mammalian cortex,
and one can take out a part of that,
segment it similar to what Mark has shown,
and you can get all the
intercellular organelles,
endoplasmic reticula, the mitochondria,
and mine it for various details,
or the bottom, maybe even
label all the vesicles.
It's up to the biologists
how they begin to mine
this kind of information,
but it is accessible.
So where do we go from here?
I think next we'll continue on trying
to acquire the fly brain atlas.
That's gonna be a little
bit of a longer-term effort
and that'll be, then, combined with all
the neural processing
to get the synaptic details
and the connectivity diagram,
and then that'll be
absorbed by other scientists
with light imaging and behavior
to really understand the circuitry.
I think, going on to the
next level beyond that,
after we have one nice, complete brain,
you begin to look at differences.
And I think this will be
another exciting phase
for this field where we look
at fly-to-fly difference.
In the semi-conductor industry,
if you wanna do failure analysis,
you do die-to-die.
Two computer chips, take two images,
subtract them from another,
if there's a difference,
that's a error, you throw it out,
or you know where the problem is.
Here, we have to do a
similar version, fly-to-fly,
and the differences could
be in development stage,
not being overwhelmed
by all the background,
or is there experience, is there memory,
can we pull it out?
Is it gonna be represented
in this EM data or not?
But I think it'll be just,
you know, fascinating time.
Thanks for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- So what I'd like to tell you about today
is our efforts to get a high
temporal and spatial resolution
of changes in membranes in the cell.
And what we're doing is
using electron microscopy
with a technique that's
called flash and freeze.
And the key to this
technique is to be able
to synchronize this cell
at a particular time
and then look at events
that occur afterward.
And so we've come up with two methods
for synchronizing cellular activity.
The first is light stimulation
and the second is electrical stimulation,
so I'll tell you about both of those.
So the way a synapse works is shown here.
I think a lot of you
are familiar with that.
This is the vision of Bernard Katz.
And here's the cell body of the neuron
and an action potential
travels down this axon
and then invades the bouton,
the presynaptic bouton,
and what that does is open
voltage gated calcium channels.
And calcium channels then open up
and cause the fusion of synaptic vesicles
filled with neurotransmitter to fuse
at the plasma membrane and
release those molecules
onto ligand gated ion channels
on the postsynaptic surface.
And so at the time, this was not believed.
It was thought that
these synaptic vesicles
that were observed did in
fact contain neurotransmitter,
but they were just storage
organelles for neurotransmitter.
And the reason was that no
one had seen these vesicles
actually fuse with the plasma
membrane after a stimulus,
and so it wasn't clear that this part
of the hypothesis was correct.
And it took some 23 years
before that was proven.
And that was proven by the work
of John Heuser and Tom Reese
because they built a
really cool instrument
called the freeze slammer,
and that's what's shown here.
So they have a piece of
the frog pectoral muscle,
which is really thin and
can freeze very rapidly,
and then they have nerves
that are still attached
and wrapped around stimulating wires.
And these stimulating wires,
this whole apparatus was
attached here to this rod
and the stimulating wires went up
and could be connected to a circuit.
And so what they could do then
was release this solenoid,
and then as the bar was
falling through space,
they would calculate five milliseconds
before it hit a copper
block, cooled to four Kelvin,
stimulate the motor neurons,
which would then cause
an action potential,
the release of neurotransmitter
at the neuro muscular junction.
And then they could ask whether
the vesicles actually fused.
And this is the image they got out of it,
absolutely spectacular.
So here is a frog neural muscular junction
which has not been stimulated.
You can see that there are
vesicles that are docked
at that surface, and it stimulated
and then frozen five milliseconds later,
you see these beautiful
fusions that are taking place
of the synaptic vesicles
fusing with the plasma membrane
and releasing neurotransmitter.
So Katz' quantal and vesicle
hypothesis was thereby proved.
But Tom and John also recognized
that there was another problem.
And that is that there
was a limited number
of synaptic vesicles at a synapse.
And so at a neuro muscular
junction maybe there's 300.
And a mouse neuromuscular
junction can fire
at 100 times a second, so at these rates,
you can see that the
synaptic vesicles could be
rapidly consumed and then
you would exhaust the synapse
and it would no longer be functional.
And so they then were convinced that these
synaptic vesicles had
to be recycled locally.
It would take a week for
vesicles to be transported
down the axom to replenish a synapse,
so there had to be local recycling.
And so what they did was they used
their freeze slammer once again.
And now, instead of
freezing five milliseconds
after stimulation, would freeze one second
and then two seconds,
10 seconds, 15 seconds,
to 30 seconds, and then look
at each of those stages and see
whether they could see
membrane being taken back in.
Now this is a freeze fracture,
so what they've done is
they've taken their ice block
and they've hit it with
a wedge on the side,
and that ice block will break
where the weak parts are.
So where are the weak parts?
It's where the lipid bilayers are,
so there's no covalent bonds
between those lipid bilayers.
Everything else is frozen
and stuck together,
so when they strike the block,
it splits at the lipid bilayer,
they can coat that with an
electron-dense material,
take those replicas, and put them
in the electron microscope,
and this is what they saw.
At zero milliseconds, that
is an unstimulated synapse,
you could see these little buttons,
and those are likely
to be calcium channels.
At five milliseconds after stimulation,
they could see these indentations,
and these are vesicles
that are on the other side
of the screen, right,
we're looking at the face
of the synapse, those are now fusing
with the membrane and
creating these dimples.
Then they looked at one
second and three seconds,
10 seconds and so on,
and they saw nothing.
And it wasn't until 30
seconds that they began to see
these proteins would come
together and form clusters
and then they would be pulled inside,
so you see these little dips.
This one in particular is beautiful
because you can see the
neck where it broke off
because, of course, you can't break into
that concave surface.
When they looked at cross sections,
they saw that these
invaginations were coated
with this electron-dense material
and it had been seen
before, this is clathrin.
They now were able to
say that at synapses,
after stimulation, that
vesicles or membranes
that are lost to the plasma membrane,
are recycled via this
clathrin-mediated process,
and the process is rather slow,
it takes about 30 seconds.
So we have revisited those experiments
and I think we see another
process that's occurring.
We call this ultrafast
endocytosis and in this case,
we see that the membrane
is removed from the surface
between 50 to 300 milliseconds
in a mouse neuron.
This then generates a synaptic
endosome within one second.
These are budded by clathrin
into mature synaptic vesicles
that can be refilled and
reused in five seconds.
So the process that we're
observing is much faster
than what had been observed
by Heuser and Reese.
When we started these experiments,
we needed a way to replicate
the freeze slammer,
we needed to freeze the
samples as quickly as possible
and it needed to be deep
because the first organism
that we did this in was C. elegans,
and so it's 80 to 100 microns thick,
so we needed to have a frozen
sample all the way through
So the way that a
high-pressure freezer works,
it goes from one to 2,000
atmospheres in 15 milliseconds.
So the water molecules
are vibrating around,
but under high pressure
they become sluggish.
And if you can drop the
temperature fast enough,
then you don't have
time for those molecules
to reorder themselves and
then generate ice crystals.
Ice crystals will shred your cells,
so there will be no morphology left.
And so by doing this, we're
able to freeze the sample
without any distortions from ice crystals.
The experiments I'm gonna show you here
are not done in C.
elegans and the nematode,
they're done in cultured
hippocampal neurons.
And so now what we need
to do is we have these
in the high-pressure
chamber, but we need some way
to initiate a deep polarization
that will then initiate
that action potential and
then stimulate this synapse
so that we can look for vesicle fusions
and endocytosis at that synapse.
And the way we're doing that
is with channelrhodopsin,
so channelrhodopsin is a
light-activated ion channel.
When you stimulate it
with 470 nanometer light,
you can then open that
channel and sodium will flow
into that neuron and then
cause an action potential.
So we now have a way to
stimulate an action potential
in a neuron that's deep inside
this high-pressure chamber.
So let me just show you
that this actually works.
Here is a neuron that's
expressing channelrhodopsin,
this is on-cell configuration.
We stimulate with light and
here is the light stimulus,
it's 10 milliseconds long, and you can see
these beautiful action potentials
that are occurring during
the light stimulus.
Usually there's just one,
but in this case we see that there are
two axion potentials occurring.
We can then move that pipette
to a post-synaptic neuron
that is not expressing channelrhodopsin,
so it will not be stimulated by light,
but it will receive
inputs from this neuron.
So we flash the light, that
now fires an action potential
and what we can see are
these post-synaptic currents.
These are synaptic
currents, they're beautiful,
and you can see in this case we also had
two action potentials that were leading
to this post-synaptic current.
So then we now have a
neuron that's expressing
channelrhodopsin in our
high-pressure chamber,
but we need to get a light
path into that chamber.
And so we modified the
Leica high-pressure freezer
at the time, and so it is
composed of this structure here.
So here's the specimen cup,
that's where our neurons
are going to go, and it's
held in place by a bayonet.
And this bayonet will
then fire down a rail
into the high-pressure chamber,
the chamber will close,
and then it fires and freezes the sample.
So what we did was we,
here's this little cup
that holds the neurons,
there's a black diamond anvil here,
and the pressure comes
here and slams out against
that black diamond anvil and
creates 2,000 atmospheres.
Liquid nitrogen flows around
on either side to freeze the sample.
So what we did was we
replaced that sapphire,
the black anvil with a sapphire anvil,
we then drilled out that mounting screw,
and we drilled out the bayonet
so that we had an LED right at this point
and now we have a light
path to the sample.
So the experiment now is quite simple.
We're going to provide a
10-millisecond light stimulus,
and then we'll freeze at 15
milliseconds, 30 milliseconds,
50 milliseconds, 100 milliseconds,
300 milliseconds, et cetera.
These were the first images we got,
and we were extremely excited by these
'cause they're just beautiful.
So if we freeze 15 milliseconds
after the stimulation,
we see vesicles fusing
with the plasma membrane.
It's just, isn't that beautiful?
It's collapsing into the membrane.
Here at 30 milliseconds,
almost fully collapsed into the membrane.
So we can capture those very rapid events
caused by an action potential
causing vesicles to fuse.
So what about recycling, right?
Remember, it took 30 seconds in the Heuser
and Reese experiments and we came up,
we saw he had a huge
surprise when we saw that
recycling of the membrane was occurring
on the scale of 100 milliseconds.
So here's the active zone,
that's where vesicles are fusing,
and at the lateral edge,
at 50 milliseconds,
you can already see this
invagination that's building.
At 100 milliseconds it's much deeper,
and this one you can actually see
some electron-dense material.
The membrane is being
cut from the surface,
so that is the act of endocytosis.
And then at 300 milliseconds,
you can see that the vesicle's
been completely cleaved from the membrane.
So we can now calculate the
time during which endocytosis
is taking place, and that is seen
by quantifying the number of each
of these structures we see.
We see the first pits at 30 milliseconds,
then we see large vesicles
form at 50 milliseconds,
we see the last pits
forming at 300 millisecond
and so that determines the
first presence of vesicles
and the last presence of
the appearance of vesicles.
So endocytosis is taking place
between 50 to 300 milliseconds.
So this is a tomogram, and
it's really an important image.
So I wanna spend a minute on it.
So what we've done here
is done a tilt series
and reconstructed the electron densities
inside that thick section.
And we have now drawn this membrane,
the presynaptic membrane,
slightly transparent.
You can see the postsynaptic
density which is shown in red
through the membrane, and so that defines
where the synaptic
vesicles are being released
and where the receptors
are on the other side.
In this synapse, you
can see that there are
three synaptic vesicles
fusing at this point
in this active zone.
Look here, already you can
see these invaginations
that are taking place at the
lateral edge of this synapse.
This means that the membrane
that is in the synaptic vesicle
and is fusing is not the same membrane
that is being taken up
by ultrafast endocytosis.
Here at 100 milliseconds,
the fusions have fully
collapsed into the membrane.
Here is one of those shallow invaginations
and here's one that's being
cleaved from the surface,
the active endocytosis.
So we're able to then follow what happens
to this membrane later,
and what you can see
is that it is transported
to the back of the synapse,
and it makes these large
synaptic endosomes, shown here,
and then this synaptic endosome
is then cut apart by a clathrin
into individual synaptic vesicles,
and here is a 3D view of that.
And if we just focus on one of these buds,
when you just look at the
densities, you can see that,
in fact, there's a clathrin
geodesic dome or buckyball
forming around one of these vesicles.
So that was great.
We're able to see this new process
called ultrafast endocytosis.
But it came under a lot of criticism,
and I think it valid if you are trying
to make a major claim here.
One of our reviewers said that there are
40 years of experiments
that suggest that clathrin mediated
into cytosis is the mechanism
by which synaptic vesicles
are recycled, and there's
probably 10,000 papers,
and now there's one paper that says
it's not the way it works.
So the major thing people were focusing on
is that we were seeing four
synaptic vesicle equivalents
being endocytosed and so why,
and the dogma is that there's
only one vesicle fusing.
There are people who think
that that's not true,
that there are multivesticular
release, but nevertheless,
that's how people imagine
the synapse works.
And they all hinged on the
fact that we were using
channelrhodopsin instead
of electrical stimulation,
which is what everybody else uses.
I actually have to thank my critics
because they were relentless,
but they're well-meaning
because all of these criticisms were told
to my face at meetings and they said,
you've got it, figure this out.
And so the ideas were that
there's an excess depolarization
by channelrhodopsin, that's possible.
There's increased membrane
fluidity by channelrhodopsin,
eh, but also possible,
and that there was calcium
influx by channelrhodopsin
as well and that was leading
to these greater responses
and this unusual form of endocytosis.
So the solution is obvious,
come up with a way to stimulate
these samples electrically,
and we call this zap and freeze.
I have to give credit to
my senior research fellow
who came up with this, Wayne Davis.
He said, this is what you're
middle plate looks like
in the center of that
high-front pressure chamber.
And the sample is held right
here, and so the light comes in
and stimulates that sample
and causes the neurons
to fire action potentials.
So he said, why don't you
just move the sample holder,
the sample cup, to this lateral position,
add stimulating leads, add capacitors
that will carry a charge, and then add
a light-activated switch so
that when you now take this,
insert it into the high-pressure chamber,
the light will stimulate that switch
and then cause a
depolarization of the cells
in your sample and
cause action potentials.
And so this is what we did,
this is what this thing looks like.
It is a independent little circuit board
that fits deep into the
high-pressure chamber.
You can see the capacitors here,
and here is where our specimens go,
and then the leads are on either side.
And so these are the images,
the first images that
came from this device.
Here is an unstimulated sample,
and then here is a stimulated sample.
This is one action potential
at 1.2 millimoles of calcium,
so this is physiological, and you can see
that there are three
vesicles that have fused
with the membrane and are collapsing
into the plasma membrane.
So this is frozen after a single stimulus
and frozen 11 milliseconds
after the pulse.
So what about ultrafast endocytosis?
So now what we've done
is we stimulate once,
it's a one-millisecond pulse,
and then we freeze 100 milliseconds later.
And now, again, here's the active zone.
Postsynaptic densities marked here.
And here is an invagination,
here is an invagination,
here is an invagination, and
here is another invagination.
At the lateral edge of the active zone,
once again showing that
ultrafast endocytosis takes place
even with electrical stimulation.
So here's quantitation of that.
Here's an unstimulated
sample and here's a sample
stimulated 100 milliseconds earlier,
and we see the presence of these
endocytic pits and endocytic vesicles.
So it looks like ultrafast
endocytosis takes place
along with, well,
we'll see when a clathrin-mediated
endocytosis occurs, but we
see these very fast responses
that disagree with what
people have been seeing
in hippocampal neurons.
So the issue is why do our
results differ from those
who have been imaging
hippocampal neurons in the past?
And I think we know the answer now,
and the answer is temperature.
So we did all of our experiments
at either 34 degrees,
because that's where
electrophysiologists like to record,
or 37 degrees, which is
physiological for the mouse.
And when we do that, we see these large
endocytic vesicles forming and
we see ultrafast endocytosis.
When Shigeki did his
experiments at 22 degrees,
you now see that clathrin-mediated
endocytosis takes over,
so you can see a clathrin coat there.
Here's an enlargement of
that beautiful clathrin coat.
So what we think is going
on is at 34 degrees,
we see normal, we see
ultrafast endocytosis.
And then at 22 degrees, we
see clathrin-coated pits
and clathrin-mediated endocytosis.
So in conclusion, we think that normally
we have ultrafast
endocytosis, removing membrane
from the surface after action potentials.
And then, in the absence
of ultrafast endocytosis,
there's an emergency backup system,
which is clathrin-mediated endocytosis.
And with that, I would just like to thank
the people who did the work.
All of the electron microscopy was done
by Shigeki Watanabe, who has his own lab
now at Johns Hopkins.
Instrumentation was from Wayne Davis.
I'd really like to thank
the people at Leica,
particularly Cveta Tomova.
They provided us with every
one of their instruments
every summer at MBL, and they would say
do whatever you want to it, we just need
to take a picture of it
at the end of the summer.
And so I have no financial
interest in Leica.
We turned over all
intellectual property to Leica,
and so these things are
now available commercially,
and you can use them.
And then finally, my host in
Berlin, Christian Rosenmund.
Thank you for listening.
(audience applauding)
- All right, so the question
that we are studying in my lab
is how does something
as complex as the brain
form in the course of
embryonic development?
How do the first circuits develop,
how do they become functionally active,
how do they perform the first computations
and instruct the first behaviors?
And so because all of these aspects
are highly dynamic aspects,
we spent quite a large
fraction of our time, actually,
also developing technology that allows us
to visualize and also measure,
at the cellular level and
at even smaller scales,
what's happening during the development
and the emergence of function
in the nervous system.
And so I'd just like to
start with two examples
of microscopes and imaging assays
we've developed for this purpose.
What you can see here is
a live imaging experiment
with a nuclei labeled to sample an embryo
going through embryo genesis,
and we can basically follow
all of the different cells
as they move and divide and specifically
reconstruct the formation
of the early nervous system.
So the structure is the equivalent
of the vertebrae spinal
cord has been formed here.
So we have this lineage reconstruction
and the morphodynamic building plan
of the early nervous system.
Now complementing this
(mumbles) perspective,
we also like to capture what's happening
in the individual neuron response
to neuro system's really up and running,
so we need tools that are even faster,
now imaging at 100 times higher speed
and even larger volumes.
This is the brain of the larval zebrafish
where we have about 100,000 neurons,
and using calcium
indicators, we can follow
the activity during
different types of behaviors.
And so from these whole brain
functional imaging recordings,
we can then figure out what
kind of circuits are involved
in certain types of behaviors
and what kind of networks
across the brain are
communicating with each other
and are jointly involved in
certain types of computations.
And so I chose these two examples, also,
because in both of these cases,
these imaging experiments
mark the first time that an
analysis like this was possible.
This was the first time that
we could actually track cells
systematically across
a higher invertebrate
and the first time that we
could image neural activity
at the cellular level
across a vertebrate brain.
And what's made it possible
to do these types of,
you know, to record
these types of data sets,
to do these types of analysis,
is the concept of light-sheet microscopy.
So I'd just like to
remind you very briefly
what the key concept is
behind this technique.
It's actually a very old technique,
it's been around for more than 100 years,
makes it twice as old
as confocal microscopy.
And to the present day,
the fundamental concept
has basically remained the same.
What we're doing is we're
illuminating a sample
with a thin sheet of
light, of laser light,
that is entering the sample
chamber from the side,
so we're selectively illuminating
a thin volume section
in the sample and then the
fluorescence that is emitted
by this thin section is imaged
with a conventional light
for detections of system
oriented at a right angle
to this incident light sheet,
so we have this detection objective
and then a camera for the (mumbles) arm.
It takes a snapshot of that
plane, of that thin section,
and so that makes this
technique a very fast
imaging technique
because with one snapshot
we can capture millions of
volume elements across this plane
and we can rapid 3D imaging by just moving
the light sheet through
the sample step by step,
just recording the image sequence.
And so then we're basically just limited
by the speed of the detector.
The camera can get giga
(mumbles) per second
with modern CMOS cameras.
But it's also a very gentle technique.
And so it's gentle because
we are only sending light
exactly to the part of the
sample that we're taking
the image off of in any point in time.
We're not sending light
to out-of-focus regions,
we're not breaching or
damaging parts out of focus.
And so this combination is
really important for our work.
And so now I'd like to be
a little more quantitative
about the imaging
experiments I just showed you
on the first two slides, and
as a reference, you know,
just embed this, basically
embed these experiments
in the parameter space that
we would care about a lot.
In most of these live-imaging experiments,
we are looking at the size
of the sample we can image,
the duration for which we can image it,
and the spatial and temporal
resolution we can achieve.
And so as a reference
point, now just connecting
to Daniel's talk again, I think
Daniel made this nice point
that if you use a
state-of-the-art spinning disk
confocal microscope, a very
powerful, fast imaging device,
you can still kind of do this
experiment of tracking cells
in a C. elegans embryo, but only up
to a certain point of time.
If you go too far into
development, and the embryo
moves so quickly that you
can't follow the cells anymore.
This is kind of like at the
limit of the performance
of the system, and so that
puts us somewhere here
in this parameter space.
And so I'm sure you've heard of the work
of my colleague Eric Betzig at Janelia,
who's also using light-sheet microscopy
to push spatial resolution
in these experiments.
So he's able to get these
really dramatic improvements
in spatial resolution of
more than a factor of 10,
same model system, and so
using these really, really thin
light sheets, either using vessel beams
or latter-slide sheet techniques.
So for us to challenge
has been a different one.
We wanted to stay at
the single cell level,
but scale this up to a much,
much larger model system.
So for the Drosophila we're
imaging at 1,000 times
larger volume, we still
want to follow cells
at the same speed, at
the same volume rate.
And then if you put it
into the functional realm,
we need to image not only at
1,000 times larger volume,
but also image that volume
at a 100 faster volume rate.
So this is where light-sheet microscopy
has been really helpful to us.
But if you look at these different
data points in this plot,
there's one thing that's
really unsatisfying about it,
and that's they're seemingly,
the implication here
is that there's seemingly this trade off.
You can either image a fairly small sample
at very high resolution
or a fairly large volume
sort of at a cellular level very quickly,
but you can't do both at the same time.
And so I think what we
really want is a technique
that allows us to image
a fairly less volume,
like the brain of a larval zebrafish,
over long periods of time
over developmental time
scales, doing during behaviors,
both at high spatial and
high temporal resolution.
And so I'd like to show you, first,
it's amazing how we can get to this part
in the parameter space.
And so the goal here is really
to find a way to add
this fourth parameter,
and three of the four parameters
we're kind of happy with,
we have the large volume,
we have the high speed,
but what is missing is
the spatial resolution,
so how can we add spatial
resolution to this mix
without trading off,
sacrificing any other parameter?
Let's look at the challenge first.
What's the problem we need to solve?
The reason why spatial
resolution is not as high
as we would want it to
be in these experiments
is that we suffer, in
many light microscopes,
in fact, from anisotropic
spatial resolution.
So the problem here is that
we are not really collecting
all of the light that
is provided by object.
So we have a limited numerical aperture,
we're only collecting light on a certain
small angular range and so this anisotropy
in sampling information
results in an anisotropy
in the way in which we form the image
and represent the samples.
We have, typically, much
lower axial resolution
than lateral resolution, as
Daniel pointed out earlier.
Ideally what we would want
to have is axial resolution
be as good as lateral resolution,
so that would be a big step forward.
I mean, light-sheet microscopy
often has a factor of 10
that we're talking about,
and then on top of that,
it would be biologically
much more meaningful
because we're treating all of
the dimensions the same way,
which makes much more sense.
What we need to find now is
a way to solve this problem
without compromising any of the
other aspects of performance
because for all experiments,
it's really important
that we can maintain the
high temporal resolutions,
we can still stay in the
realm of calcium imaging,
maybe even push us forward
to (mumbles) imaging
in the future.
We really don't want to touch speed
and still get imaging at
the whole brain level.
So the way we can do this is
we combine light-sheet imaging
with another fairly old concept,
and that's the concept of multi-imaging.
What we do in this approach
is that, counterintuitively,
the first step is that we don't solve
this problem of anisotropic resolution.
We simply accept the fact
that if we, let's say,
have a point-like object,
the image that we get is ellipsoid,
so like this distorted representation.
So we have low resolution
along the axial component,
high resolution laterally.
But then in the next step, what we do
is we rotate the sample 90 degrees
relative to the microscope,
and so we caught a second
view of the same scene.
And so now we have permuted the dimensions
along which resolution's
high and low respectively,
and taken together
across these two images,
we have actually almost all
of the frequency content
that we're interested in of our sample,
and we basically just have
to register these two views
and combine them, for
example, with a process
called multi-view deconvolution
and then we have this
near-isotropic spatial resolution.
So that would be a powerful way
to improve spatial resolution
because we can just keep
our microscope and the
way in which we build
our light sheets the way it is.
Basically the main challenge
that we have to solve now
is to find a way to record
these multiple views
at the same time, then we haven't
sacrificed a poor resolution.
And so Raghav Chhetri,
a postdoc in my lab,
addressed this problem,
and built a microscope that can do that.
And so here's the idea.
It's a little bit, the arrangement's
a little bit more complex
and it's basally the idea
as I described, so we
don't only have two views
of the sample, we actually
have four opposing objectives.
So it gives us four following views,
which simply means that
we can scale this idea up
to larger specimens that are
not entirely transparent.
So for Drosophila and zebrafish
it's actually very helpful,
also for mouse, mouse
embryos that we are studying.
But now the problem is, if
you sent in four light sheets
at the same time from
all these four objectives
and then take four images,
light for the images
for these objectives,
we've violated a fundamental concept
of the optical sectioning concept
in light-sheet microscopy.
So we've actually sent in, light in a way
that we now illuminate
out-of-focus structures
with respect to the
respective other light sheets.
So we get out a focus
slide, we basically degrade
the image quality
by doing this at the same time.
So the way we can solve this
is that we don't actually
use light sheets in our
light-sheet microscopes.
What we do is we send in a
very, very thin pencil beam,
and so then if you take this pencil beam
and you scan it up and down very quickly
across your plane of
interest and just keep
the camera shutter open,
you get the equivalent
of a light sheet, that's
like a scanned light sheet.
If you use this concept now
and implement it in a way
that the beams that come in
from these different views
are slightly offset in
space, so we keep them maybe
a couple of tenths of microns apart,
and then we scan them across
their respective planes
at a constant pace so they maintain
that same constant distance,
so they never cross
their paths in real space,
then all we need to do is match this up
with a set of confocal line
detectors that really only
detect the light that comes
from that beam and blocks out
the light that comes
from the (mumbles) beam,
they're slightly offset in space,
it's just hitting the
detector at the wrong spot,
not at the rolling shutters
at that point in time.
We have the same trace offset in our
confocal line detectors,
everything is matched up
and synchronized, and now
we can scan four views
at the same time without
any signal crosstalk.
So that's the key idea in
what we call the isotropic
multi-view light-sheet
microscope, the ISU microscope.
And so here's the data we
can get with this approach.
Again, the low anisotropic resolution
in the contributing views,
but if you combine these views
into one single image,
cause it's a multi-view
deconvolved image, we now
have isotropic resolution,
you can turn this in any way, and
you don't have any perceived difference
in spatial resolution.
This is a GCaMP expressing
Drosophila larva
in a GCaMP (mumbles) system.
So let me just zoom in onto
this cluster of neurons
so you can actually see the
impact on spatial resolution.
So now with contributing views,
we have one dimension
along which it's very hard
to distinguish these individual neurons.
They're just blurring into each other.
In the other set of views
is a different dimension
but the same problem but then
combining all this information
into the S view construction,
we now have high resolution for
any view along the XYZ axes.
And so we've basically
restored cellular resolution,
even in these deeper regions
of the nervous system.
Normally, we find about four
nanometer spatial resolution.
And so because we haven't
sacrificed temporal resolution,
we can now do these types of
functional imaging experiments.
For example, imaging at
the whole animal level,
the entire Drosophila
larvae expressed in GCaMP
during motor behaviors,
we can see forward,
backward crawling and then
sort of concurrent calcium
activity that is
orchestrating this behavior
in the ventral nerve course
areas, you see these waves
in the B and C,
and sort of a similar
context in the zebrafish,
so we have a larval zebrafish here
that executing different
types of swimming behaviors,
and you can see this
activity in the hind brain
and the spinal cord
during these behaviors.
This image is at two hertz
and this is at one hertz,
and it's just rotating the
fish, but as you can see,
there is no change in resolution
as we rotate the volume.
So I think live imaging
is where it really unfolds
its full potential,
but you can, of course,
also use it for structural
imaging experiments
with fixed samples.
So the main gain is that you
gain isotropic resolution,
you can image it very quickly,
so this is now an expanded
Drosophila brain combined
with expansion microscopy,
so that makes it, actually,
about two millimeters long
along each side, and so
within about 15 minutes
we get then 100 nanometer
isotropic spatial resolution
across the brain.
Then sort of like a sparse
pattern of fruitless neurons
that are labeled here,
and so if you zoom in,
you can see the fine structural details
which can aid (mumbles) types analysis
in relatively high throughput
with these imaging experiments.
So let me just summarize this.
We have basically an
improvement of about tenfold
in resolution without sacrificing
speed and field of view.
And in more absolute quantitative terms,
that means 49 meter spatial
resolution, system resolution
at sub-second time scales for the volume
of about 800 micron cubed.
And so I just showed
you very short sequences
from, actually, longer
imaging experiments.
We've imaged these
examples for hours to days
in each of these cases, so you can use it
under physiological conditions
in this parameter space.
But one thing I'd like
to point out is that,
intentionally I said
system resolution here,
so which means this is
the performance we expect
on ideal imaging conditions if you have
a fairly transparent sample.
And unfortunately, most of
the samples we are looking at
are far from transparent,
and we're in this realm
of imaging relatively large
specimens for life imaging,
Drosophila, larval zebrafish brain,
they actually perturb the light
that we need to use to rely
on to do the measurement
in the first place, and
so this is a problem
we need to solve because
the way it impacts
our light-sheet microscope is that,
because of the heterogeneity,
the optic heterogeneity
of the samples is like this
toy model of a cross section
of a, let's say the Drosophila larva,
as the light sheets enter the sample,
they are deviated from their light path
to change their course,
so this can change further inside a sample
depending on the optical properties,
can change over time as
optical properties change,
as the sample develops,
and the same thing happens
in the detection process.
We have some increasing
curvature of the focal planes,
they're not really clean planes anymore,
they get bent as a function
of the spatial location
and as function of time.
And so bottom line is
that we lose this nice
coplanarity that we rely on
in the light-sheet microscope,
but if the light sheet should be coplane
over the focal plane to
get an in-focus image,
that's not really the case anymore,
so we basically image out of
focus and we get low resolution
and low image contrast.
And so Loic Royer, another
postdoc in the lab,
addressed this problem
in the following way.
Basically developed, first of all,
so there are two components
to this solution.
First of all, we need a
microscope that has access
to the degrees of freedom that he needed
to bend things back into shape.
We need to be able to rotate
and translate the light sheets
and the focal planes so we
can actually fix the problem
if you know what the
problem is geometrically.
And so the second part is
that we need to measure,
take the right measurements.
We have (mumbles)
deployed on the microscope
that allow us to estimate image quality
as a function of changes
in these degrees of freedom
and basically build a model of
the sample in the background
of the live imaging experiment
to constantly improve
in space and time the spatial relationship
between focal planes and light sheets.
And so with this combined sort
of adaptive imaging approach,
we can now hand the experiment
over to this real-time
control layer and
basically have it optimize
the image quality, and so for example
in a zebrafish embryo that
has the following effect,
if you look at different regions here,
try to track the cells as
they form the nervous system,
we can't really without
the adaptive imaging
follow cells in many parts
of the sample anymore
over time because the
image quality degrades.
And with the adaptive imaging approach,
we can recover that high resolution.
We can also use it in a
functional imaging context.
So this is now a zebrafish larval brain.
Again, I'm showing you the
quality with the adaptive
imaging engaged and
with all this framework.
And after some time of imaging,
you can see how quality
really degrades because
if the brain is growing,
the fish is actually
growing, and we're changing
the optical context and losing the ability
to really accurately measure activity
at the single neuron level.
And with that, I'm at the end.
Just like to give you a quick outlook.
We are now integrating these imaging tools
with optical emulation tools.
We don't only want to
watch what's happening,
we want to control what's
happening, manipulate it.
And so particularly with
a layered, it allows us
to classify behavior in real time
so that we can interact with
behavior at different stages,
at different phases, and for
example, control the state
that the (mumbles) is
in, control, for example,
motor behavior from
forward-walking to backward-walking
and so on, and so that's
the next stage now
for this technology for us.
And so with that, I'm
at the end of the talk.
And just like to acknowledge very briefly
Raghav Chhetri who built
the IsoView microscope,
Loic Roya who developed this
adaptive imaging framework,
built it, a lot of the imagings from
(mumbles) of these imaging experiments.
And then we have a lot of
fantastic collaborators
at Janelia that contributed
a lot to the work
that I showed you here, Misha
Ahrens and Kristin Branson
in particular, to whom I'm very grateful.
All right, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)